I want to ask you though speaking of
that like growing up like what were like
I don't know what was like one of your
favorite rom-coms growing up
it's hard it's hard it is hard so many I
just went through so many I love uh
Moonstruck oh I love Moon stuff nice
um I mean growing up so we're going back
I love working girl When Harry Met Sally
yeah you know and we don't get those
movies in movie theaters anymore you
know and they probably get them made
they don't get made like Sleepless so
thank you for making one you've got mail
exactly we just wanted to make a movie
like that because make a movie that
makes you feel good when you leave the
theater and hopeful and you know usually
people don't say Moonstruck why
Moonstruck
well it's a great movie Kelly Clarkson
is usually not the one people say why
that one for you
um if that was a huge movie when I was
growing up and I love Cher gay yeah
um and I love sharing she won the Oscar
it's a great I also grew up in New York
it's a great New York movie it makes New
York really magical and um that's why I
love You've Got Mail yeah I love you I
was like oh I should I should definitely
move there and start a children's
bookstore like I actually we just had
our New York premiere of bros in the
movie theater where I remember seeing
You've Got Mail the day it opens and we
actually very specifically talk about
You've Got Mail in Bros in a funny way
and um that was very mad that's my
that's my favorite one I think that
sticks out I love pretty woman oh yeah
it's like I looked pretty woman
on the opportunity
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]